all right we're live all right so what's
up everyone we are back at the
blockchain economic forum we are now
with Dylan and Jason Oh what's up guys
it's great life's great life is great
for sure it is and you are with monarch
monarch token and we are going to be
talking about the importance of monarch
token what you guys are doing so why
don't you guys give a rundown of monarch
token from what from what I remember you
were like it's so much easier to have
reoccurring payments come in for people
in a in a way that is unique because I
don't I don't own you don't own the key
I don't own the key we own half of the
key each which which mate which is
completely decentralized which is
exciting we want to learn more about
this so let's let's do it who wants to
kick us off so what monarch token is is
an all-in-one platform for recurring
payments on the blockchain that is for
investors and also for consumers and
additionally for most importantly
merchants so currently there's no real
good way to receive blockchain payments
or rather to receive crypto payments if
you are a merchant or offer some sort of
service there's a few but they're just
not very good so in addition with Mikey
up online and people can take either QR
scan or they can enter Mikey copy and
paste and pay me that way well by and
large cryptocurrency is a push
technology
first of all I've got to get your wallet
address I've got to send the transaction
to you there's no way for me to request
payment right so if I have a
subscription-based service there's no
way for me to request interesting I
would have to look into I'm not aware of
that so far but you could be correct I
don't know what I do know is that
monarch is in a fully decentralized
manner we are using a patented
technology called multi signature wallet
leasing effectively I think you were
touching on that is right so we own half
a private key and yes
so effectively three conditions must be
met for us to be able to transact on
your behalf the amount the destination
and the
Quincy so we like to use the Netflix
example you want to pay $9.99 every 30
days to Netflix if those three
conditions are met the smart contract
executes all you need to do to stop that
transaction from occurring is login to
your app and switch it off it revokes
our access because we never hold your
private keys you always retain
possession of your private keys
you always retain possession of your
funds there are other solutions that
offer a similar outcome but not in a
decentralized manner yes so another fun
exciting part about monarch is the CMS
plugin so that being a content
management system 90% of websites online
are built on WordPress or Squarespace or
wicks and Shopify even as well a lot of
people build their own stores through
Shopify and what we do is we've created
a plugin that you can go directly on
your website to be able to take these
number one recurring payments as well as
Fiat as well as the one-time crypto
payments as well so that way we actually
enable others to now accept this but the
best part of all is gonna be that you
can pay in crypto and we will pay the
business and Fiat so that way it would
truly will be a mass adoption tool
because what business doesn't want more
money coming in in the form of Fiat ok
so so let's run run me through an
example then so I throw up a website
that gives people access to certain
content or product for ten dollars a
month and then where is the they paid
they pay through monarch token to me
because I have a monarch token CMS plug
in and then then who then who do you pay
and fiat then at that point where is
that we will then pay the business and
fiat we do take it - so then you rather
than paying me so if you were buying the
$10.00 per month product for me then
rather than paying let's actually use
the three of us make this a better
example so I'm Netflix
Jason is monarch you are the customer
you will send your ten dollars in
Bitcoin to monarch and monarch will
therefore pay Netflix in Fiat which
makes it a full solution
so now why would a company like Bitcoin
or theorem or ripple or any of these
other cryptocurrencies why wouldn't they
make a monthly reoccurring ability to
pay they do not have the patent to do
that in a decentralized manner so okay
so you have a patent - for this multiple
signature wallet leasing and fully
decentralized because you don't own the
private key and I don't know in the
private key we each own half of the
private key but ultimately but
ultimately you are you retain possession
of the private key we are only allowed
to utilize it on your behalf from the
backend as long as you have your
subscription set to the active format to
revoke our access to the private key all
you need to do is switch it off inside
the app so effectively if you want to
cancel your subscription you move out of
your house and you were paying your rent
with it you want to shut off the power
bill etc all you do is log into the
wallet revoke our access we can no
longer execute that smart contract so
then it's all happening via smart
contracts so then it is if let's contain
monarch to pay Netflix so then there's a
smart contract between monarch and
Netflix that's where the smart contract
side of things I pay you and then yourse
month the smart contract is here per
month and then at any point the flick
the switch is flicked off one thing that
I do want to say is for the consumer
it's not like they're going to pay
monarch as an external source it's
embedded in their website so they really
just think that they are sending it
directly to Netflix but there's a
back-end process that happens that
monarch receives that crypto payment and
then pays Fiats so effectively all they
know is they're sending Bitcoin or
whatever token they're supporting they
send the token they get their service
that's all that matters because that's
what's important to them so then does
the CMS plugin look a little bit like
whatever cryptocurrency you want to pay
with you can pay with
that is in the development roadmap of
Manar and then so so then the we did the
Netflix example that's probably really
relatable for people right now if you
pay with US dollars are you paying a fee
do you know to Netflix that's a good
question um I I know we yeah and then if
you do credit card processing fee maybe
through the bank there is no credit card
processing fee maybe the bank there are
of course other things that you pay for
with your bank account as well but by
having a bank account you pay for other
things so now for example if I was to
pay with with cryptocurrency instead am
I not paying more money and it takes
more time for it to be verified it's
nice that it's on a mutable
decentralized ledger that's cool but but
is there really any other purpose right
now besides it being on that ledger if I
have to pay more for it if the
transaction takes longer that's a good
question actually so I mean ultimately
you've got to understand there's a
little bit of volatility in the price of
cryptocurrencies currently anyway as
more market adoption happens hopefully
we see more you know more regulation
comes and we see more stability in the
prices of these coins but ultimately it
really what we're just trying to do is
we've we've seen enough people that are
operating in the cryptocurrency space
that are in a manner like you said where
they want to have something they want to
be able to accept Bitcoin or aetherium
or whatever it is as a payment for their
service whether they're holding out is a
speculative investment or immediately
converting that into fiat our main goal
was to be able to provide a solution for
companies to be able to do that we can
do very little about what the credit
card processors are charging we can do
very little about the network fees for
Bitcoin or aetherium etc we can't do
anything about that what we can do is
reduce your transaction fees on our
network if you are holding our tokens
does that answer your question
eventually you want to reduce fees to
the point where well I can tell you for
sure so say for instance if you and I
were just sending peer-to-peer between
our wallets there's no transit there's
no transactional fees on that at all
obviously the network fee for the
currency but we're not taking it out of
that we are only taking a piece of the
merchant transactions we're still
cheaper than Visa
still cheaper than American Express and
MasterCard and again providing an avenue
exactly you're looking at about 4.9 I
think for visa and I think it's three
percent roughly for American Express so
either way I think it's too so yeah
but the speed doesn't necessarily beat
it nor does nor does uh
only whatever point zero zero one
percent of all locations take monarch
right now so you know what I mean
so that everywhere it takes V so right
now almost so that is the difference not
you know
I know many people that would much
prefer to pay the rent because in crypto
because they have much more crypto than
Fiat in their bank account per se so you
know I'm sure there will be a lot of
people you know again we will see in the
actual adoption of monarch but I'm quite
confident that there are many people out
there that would prefer to pay Netflix
in Bitcoin yeah the adoption of
blockchain and decentralization
technologies for cryptocurrency and
beyonds very exciting what else are you
looking forward to regarding
decentralization Technologies personally
something that I'm a fan of is setting
up these trusted protocols so that we no
longer have to I mean this is
unfortunately a textbook crypto example
but realistically setting up these
protocols trusting in the math trusting
that electricity will provide the
governance for the system to eliminate
we don't need to trust a government
agent we don't need to trust any trusted
third party who could then seize control
or alter the fundamental function of the
way that the system works so I'm a big
fan of that about decentralization is
just the lack of any ability for one bad
actor to control it without a doubt I'm
very happy for a peer-to-peer
transactions you know that I can send
you Bitcoin not through another
organization right now if I want to send
you money
even over PayPal that's a centralized
solution that you know PayPal can say
you know peace out I'm taking your money
but obviously that doesn't happen too
often but removing that fact I think is
a is a step in the right direction for
society as a whole is where social
warriors and then
with the push for decentralization and
the power coming back into the hands of
people rather than centralized entities
what liberation are you most looking
forward to I'm a big so I've been the
victim of identity theft
myself I am a big fan of the potential
to eliminate that altogether you know
Equifax was hacked so many consumers had
their vital information put at risk
compromised and now will have to go
through extra steps for the rest of your
life trust me I know because I'm going
through it so you have to take extra
steps for the rest of your life to
prevent that even more so from happening
again so being able to eliminate that
possibility altogether I think is very
strong as well as you know and again
it's a typical crypto answer but opening
financial markets up to people that may
not have historically had it there's
probably a lot of great ideas somewhere
in Sudan or the middle of the rainforest
in Brazil that that could be
world-changing but no one will ever have
you know they they don't have the access
to try to push that forward so I think
changing that is something I'm
definitely looking forward to I mean
yeah both providing financial support
areas of the world for those ideas to
come to life but also um identity we
were just at the blocking for social
justice conference this last weekend and
we were learning about kind of like what
it would have been like if the
technology was out earlier and how that
would have affected manifest destiny and
as people were trying to conquer and
push out their borders yeah so that that
kind of comes in for people's identities
people's land etc so yeah what about you
for liberation for me he couldn't have
said it better I didn't eliminating
identity theft is truly you know massive
massive massive massive but as the I
robots come through and through and so I
would love to speak about afterwards I
definitely see a crossroads let's let's
get there right now then all right so as
as wealth is being concentrated in the
hands of so few and it's being
exacerbated by exponential technology
the bottom of the socio-economic status
is very slowly inching its
while this hops exploding upward what do
we do about wealth inequality we're
hoping that these self-governing systems
will restore a bit of control back and
and cryptocurrency by-and-large is one
of the first industries where Main
Street came before Wall Street and I
think a lot of the cult of crypto
doesn't really have an interest in
rebuilding the same system only just for
us there's there's a lot of idealism in
this space and I think that's hopefully
if people are as good as their word
that's being able to spread out wealth
being able to spread out access to
capital in amongst a wider proportion I
think overall that there's no way that
can't be good for Humanity sorry to
steal a mic I would actually like to
disagree that blockchain will not
necessarily help this although this will
be controversial
sorry blockchain folks I love it I want
mass adoption but I feel that the people
ultimately do have their choices on how
to spend and a new type of technology
will not stop poor spending habits so
therefore I feel like blockchain is not
the answer - closing the divide if
anything the people up top are gonna
multiply their money even faster by
investing through AI robots and being
able to trade and you know make the gap
therefore even bigger so I feel
blockchain will not stop that it will
not close the gap but it can help those
at the bottom
especially in third world countries
remittances let's say you grow up in
Morocco and you go over to the United
States and you are working very hard to
send your family money back crypto has a
very small fee instead of a remittance
pay so there are many uses that will
allow people to climb up the social
ladder
especially in third-world countries I
think that the immediate use case of
cryptocurrency will make the biggest
social impact in third-world countries
right now I'm working on a project that
allows teaching certifying and then
employing all in the same platform
they've contract with the government of
Ghana to try and help the social justice
so I
of impact investing I love working on
projects that truly will change the
world because you can do well and also
do good which is personal mantra of mine
I like how initially you were like
blockchains answer and then when you get
the mic back you were like blockchain is
actually gonna exacerbate wealth in
quality a little bit but it's also going
to provide some social good it's it's a
answer and as any technology that can be
used for good and bad it seems as though
with with the way that you have been
talking about social impact whether it
be through identity through social
impact across the world it seems as
though that it's going to be very
liberating in that sense it's gonna be
very fantastic in that sense but at the
same time it really does seem like the
current cryptocurrency billionaires and
the blockchain you know investors and
everything there is a good amount of
wealth inequality that's gonna come from
that explosion as well and I think we're
gonna see the same thing in 2019 from
the quantum computing explosion of
technology as well so it's very
interesting how liberating these things
are but also how exacerbating wealth
inequality they can be how about we ask
you both about do you think we're alone
in the cosmos that's mathematically
impossible this is a the place is way
too big there is no chance that that
that that we are the only consciousness
now will we other collide that's also
mathematically very difficult in a space
this large so I think it's arrogant to
think that we could be the only
intelligent life in this cosmos but
whether we will ever actually encounter
said extraterrestrials is debatable
goodness that it better myself
just take the mic back now no do you
think advanced civilizations roam the
cosmos the potential is there
to what end I mean at a certain at a
certain point if they are
technologically advanced enough what are
they out there for other than perhaps
looking for other intelligent life but I
would imagine a society that is
technologically it man
enough to be able to escape and survive
in you know in space cuz we're not
equipped for that would probably have
hopefully less need for being out to for
conquest or you know mining the universe
so to speak do you think that
consciousness is localized in the human
nervous system I think the meat sack is
a very fantastic antenna that Tunes you
into the consciousness I posit to you
that we are all facets of the same thing
experiencing itself through another lens
I recently heard a theory that there is
no past present or future it's just one
timeline that we are on and when you
think of the fast that when you think of
a past you're recalling a memory that is
currently happening when you think about
what's gonna happen in the future and
you're anticipating its immediately
happening see you just flinched
so that flinch you knew was going to
happen was it reaction was it something
that happened it's all in the same plane
and time is planar time is not
interpretive as far as I know it's the
only dimension that we don't manipulate
in our current reality we travel through
three dimensions technically we travel
through four just three of them are
manipulative all the markets in 2018
time is very fascinating glad we got
there how should we maximize the
potential of children into our world I
think by embracing what they are best at
I think that you will be fighting an
uphill battle if you are not doing what
you're best at and what do you enjoy
most and I feel like those are often
gonna be synonymous because people love
being successful and it brings natural
happiness so if you're just good at
baseball you may not necessarily just
love playing baseball because you love
being with your friends you may just
love the satisfaction of hitting that
home run because there's no feeling like
it if you play baseball so I think that
embracing people
towards success will yield happiness
which will yield exponential results
that's where well said yeah we love the
idea of being able to provide a really
strong opportunity for everyone across
the planet to be maximize their fullest
potential now what do you guys think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
being alive being alive life is
fantastic it's even with its ups and
downs even at my most depressed I still
is like you can still have a pretty good
day
where you're outside you're like well
it's whether it's great or being in Bay
Area you know I've just recently moved
to Los Angeles from San Francisco but I
can tell you many a time of just being
out for a bike ride and stopping to look
at the Marin Headlands and being like
this is where I live yeah I guess life's
a beautiful thing mm-hmm you asked the
question again what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world I
think ignorance ignorance not knowing
everything because I feel like if we
knew everything that would be such an
unsettling feeling and I think it is
beautiful that we are unaware of many
things feel like understanding
everything would feel very empowering
but yeah I would I would personally beg
to differ
no you if you knew that a family member
of yours was going to pass away in two
years from a car accident how would you
feel every day your life yeah
that's a that's a good one yeah that's a
tough one it's a good one
there's also there is something
beautiful about tapping into the source
code of the universe that that's
exciting stuff I like that idea
do you guys think there's a designer
tough to say it all works awfully well
doesn't work it all works awfully well
like if you if you think about what a
star actually is gravity it's an
explosion that has gravity being created
at the center so intensely that it pulls
the explosion back in which creates more
mass that causes another explosion
that's crazy
it's but it just it just is what it is
the nature the fundamental nature of the
universe the way it all works I can't
say there's a designer but I sure can't
say there isn't I don't think there's
one designer how many designers are
there more than you can count on your
hands who are the designers we don't
know if we knew you wouldn't be
answering this question asking this
question yeah we are the designers of
this video for sure all right cool
monarch token now Lincoln bio definitely
go check it out
Dylan Jason thanks for - thanks for
hanging out with us yeah yeah yeah we
got a good education in this multi what
is it again multi well the signature
Wallace Multi signature wallets and we
got a good there's a ignorant is power
never sorry knowledge is bliss I love
knowledge so again good stuff monarch
token Lincoln bio check him out also if
you guys had a good time go and share
with two other people they'll share with
two people subscribe comment below like
the column share it go and create with
the content as well join us on patreon
to help support us
maybe we'll get a monarch token plug-in
on the site soon for reoccurring paid so
you get that yeah I know how you need to
get there you need to get that [ __ ] role
in funding thanks everyone for tuning in
much love thanks guys